I think the best time to bond with a
child is when it's literally inside of
you a lot of the time when and the
Kardashians is spoken about this when
you have a Sara create your child
basically grow your child when they then
give it to you after the 9 months you
can't connect with it it's like picking
up a delivery literally picking up a
delivery how can you connect with it and
again I I don't know I'm not speaking
from experience I'm speaking from what
I've heard but it makes perfect sense
one thing you'll notice is when you see
pregnant women in photos they're all
doing the same thing they'll always hold
their bump because it's so natural they
have to touch the baby they have to
connect so if you're not doing that for
9 months that child isn't going to
connect with you and you're not going to
connect with it